- Those parts where
there was still progress
and where things were
still getting better
also were somehow distracting us
from the lack of
progress everywhere else.
The ways in which we're
not a progressive society,
we use the word progressive,
gets used all the time,
but it doesn't stand
for actual progress.
And you know, I always say,
you know, the iPhones that,
you know, distract us
from our environment
also distract us from the
way it's strangely old.
So you're looking at an iPhone
while you're riding a hundred
year old subway that's
completely busted in New York.
- Right.
- And so there's
something about, we have
some elements of progress,
but they've been distracting
us from, you know,
the lack of progress or
even the outright decline.
(dynamic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, live from
the local studio here in Miami.
And joining me today is the
founder of The Thiel Foundation,
the co-founder of PayPal
and Palantir, Peter Theil.
I could have given you like
a whole bigger intro there.
Anything else you wanna
throw in yourself?
- It's all good.
Generally, the
shorter the intro,
the more flattering it is.
- Oh.
- You have super long, you have
a 20 page resume for people
who've never done
anything, so it's.
- Well, I was gonna
say, Renaissance man,
disgruntled libertarian
something, something.
- The longer the intro
gets, the more it suggests
that you're not really
doing anything at all.
- Oh, all right.
Well, you are doing a lot.
I have, I actually have notes.
I never have notes when I
do a show, but I was like,
I want to cover some new ground
and not just get into
the political thing
that we're always fighting
with everybody about.
But I thought I'd start
because we are here in Miami.
You know, you famously
left San Francisco,
moved most of the
operation to Los Angeles.
You do have a place in Miami.
How do you feel about this
sort of movement of people
across the country right now
and sort of watching people
migrate to different
places to live very,
very different ways?
- Well, it's surely a very
healthy thing that, you know,
it's, in retrospect,
it's amazing that
people were as stuck
as they were in the
places they were in,
for such a long time.
And, you know, the
history of the U.S.
was that this had always been
a society where people moved
a lot between places
and the mobility,
the physical mobility
had actually gone
down probably a lot
for the last 40 or 50 years
relative to the, you know,
200 year history before that.
And so, and you know, it's,
it's probably the jury's still
a bit out whether this is a
temporary or permanent feature,
but it's surely a
healthy recalibration.
It's sort of this idea,
you can always start
over in this country,
and one of the
ways you start over
is you move to a new place.
- Were you kind of patting
yourself on the back,
that you were the first
guy outta San Francisco?
And my audience is well aware,
as I've posted some
videos from a recent visit
to San Francisco, the way
that place has just collapsed
under progressive policies
is absolutely insane.
I'm guessing you don't
have any employees
that are wishing that
you guys had stayed,
although you still do have
some people there, right?
- There still are some
people, not very many
that still are living
in San Francisco proper.
And yeah, it is
really extraordinary.
I lived in San Francisco
from 2003 to 2018,
and it sort of, you know,
it never quite got better.
But the idea, it took
a while for the idea
to sneak up on people
that it was actually
on the slow dk
deterioration thing.
You know, the homelessness
was always a chronic problem.
Circa 2014, 2015, you
started to realize,
you know, it's
actually getting worse
and they're never gonna,
it's not just that this
is this fake problem
that they're taking
a long time to fix.
It's, they are, it's a fake
problem they use to distract
from everything else,
they're never gonna fix it.
- So when you're hearing-
- But it's also a real
problem, you know.
- Well, it's also right,
it's clearly a real problem,
but something that they
either don't seem interested
in fixing, well, what do you
think is the answer to that?
They're not interested?
- There are a lot of problems
that are both real and fake.
- Yeah.
- So the homeless
problem is, you know, yeah,
it's an incredible problem,
but it's also, you get a sense
that it never gets fixed.
And so if you talk
about a problem
that you're never gonna fix,
then you can avoid talking
about all the other problems.
Like, let's say cost of living
for out of control rents
for people with homes or
broken schools or, you know,
crime or, you know, there's
sort of probably half a dozen
other issues that move to
the bottom of the queue
as long as we talk about
an unsolvable problem.
- When you were there,
were you trying to talk to them
about those things and say,
guys like, look at
what is happening here
and the state of the decay?
- Well, on the city
level, it felt like exit
is much more
powerful than voice.
- Yeah.
- You know, it is.
It was, I'm not sure
it's super corrupt,
but San Francisco
is super ideological
in this very left wing,
very un-reformable way.
And you know, it would
be, you know, it's,
I always have a schizophrenic
view about getting involved
in politics where it's
like super important
and super toxic,
but getting involved
in San Francisco City
politics, that would be,
that would be absolutely an
insane thing to do relative
to just moving.
- You're not enough of
a masochist for that.
- It's, you know,
heroism's good.
Martyrdom not so good.
And, and, and
yeah, the relative,
the relative sanity of getting
involved in local politics
or just moving out
of San Francisco, you
should always move.
- So to that point,
one more thing on this.
So now you're here
in Florida, you know,
you have a place here.
- For the winter,
last few winters, yes.
- So you're splitting time,
and obviously you also
have your place in LA.
But do you feel a real tangible
difference when you're here?
I mean, you know, I left
a year ago and it's like,
I have not looked back
and I'm loving it here,
and I see something
so incredibly powerful
and flourishing here.
Do you feel that
when you're here?
- Well, it has, you know,
there is sort of just an
extraordinary difference
if you're in a place
where you just feel
it's growing versus not.
- Yeah.
- And there's a sense
in which Florida, Texas,
have this dynamic of
where it's just growing.
You know, every
storefront is full.
There are no empty stores,
you know, everything.
It's not, I'm not sure
it's quite booming,
but it feels, you know, it
feels healthy and growing.
And then, and then, you know,
much of California does
not quite have that feel,
even though, of
course, you know,
Silicon Valley's
been this odd place
where it was a,
you know, gold rush
and everyone was depressed.
- Yeah.
- Even so for the last decade.
So Silicon Valley had
a very odd dynamic,
whereas a crazy boom that
didn't actually feel that way
if you, you know,
walk down the street
and then certainly with the
COVID shock the last few years,
it's quite different.
I still think California is
probably somewhat healthier
than New York or, you know,
completely bankrupt states
like Illinois or, you know,
non states like Puerto Rico.
- Mm-hmm.
- But.
- Why do you think
healthier than New York?
- I think, I think there are
ways that the finance industry
that New York is centered
on is more movable
than the tech industry
in California.
And probably the very big
tech companies like Google
and Apple, it's hard to
picture them actually moving
out of California.
Whereas you can
picture the big banks
gradually moving
out of New York,
and there's something
about finance
that's been a little
bit more movable.
It also paradoxically
makes it more dangerous
for California, because
if things ever go wrong,
they will be so bust.
- Right.
- It'll be like Detroit,
which thought that it had
these captive big three
car manufacturers
and could get away
with very bad policies
in Michigan, Detroit,
for decade after decade.
And then when, you know,
when that industry finally
went south, you know, it was,
it was just unfixable.
- Do you find that these-
- New York's in a worse
shape right now because
people are, you know,
relatively more
people are leaving,
it's easier for the businesses
to leave and then maybe,
maybe California if it's
not careful, you know,
it will at some point
really go off the cliff.
- Right.
Do you find that these
things sort of happen slowly
and then very quickly?
So something like California,
it's like, you know,
Callie's lost almost
a million people
in these last three years,
and a lot of them
are high earners.
I mean, these are
people who are paying
into the system
that's ever growing.
At some point, somebody has
to look at numbers, right?
And be like, none of
this works, you know,
or I guess maybe not, right?
It just continues
somehow, I suppose.
- Yeah, I actually,
I don't know how many of
them were the highest earners
in California the
last few years.
I think New York was a
little bit more that effect
than California.
But yes, these things, you know,
we have these odd dynamics
where things go on
for a very long time.
They're not ultimately
sustainable.
But, you know, there's some,
there's some way I often think
that much of the 2000s and 2010s
were this weird continuation
of the 1990s, you know.
The decades, there were things
that happened, you know,
you had 9/11, you had the
global financial crisis,
Trump election, Brexit.
There were some events that
happened in those 20 years,
but it was surprisingly little.
December, 2019, I was
reflecting on the 2010s.
And I realized there've
been no retrospectives
on this decade.
What actually
happened in the 2010s?
You know, we had
marijuana legalization,
we had "Game of Thrones,"
and people fell into
their iPhones and then,
but then it was somehow just
this thing that was sort
of a stretched, exhausted
version of the 2000s,
which themselves
were a stretched,
exhausted version
of the nineties.
And then, and then I, yeah,
I wanna say that in some
sense, you know, March, 2020,
when COVID hits, we
finally, you know,
a lot of these things
finally accelerate.
And you know, and we're
finally in the 21st century.
- So that's actually
a great segue
to sort of where I
wanted to start today.
Because years ago, once
off camera, you said to me,
"I wouldn't be a libertarian
if any of it worked."
And I just thought that
line pretty much captures
so much of what's happening,
even right this moment.
You referenced the last
three years of COVID
where it seems like nothing
really works anymore.
Our government kind
of doesn't work,
our educational institutions
don't seem to work.
The medical field
doesn't seem to work.
Is it all, is it sort of obvious
that they were all not gonna
work at the exact same time?
Or how did this happen?
- Well, you know, I'm
tempted to say the rot
has been building
up for a long time.
And, you know, if
you define technology
as doing more with less,
so many of these institutions,
educational and even healthcare
are kind of the opposite,
where you get the same for
more or you get less for more.
So it's the anti-tech definition
when you think of the public
schools probably in some sense,
the quality of the
education is way lower
than it was 50 or 60 years ago.
The costs are way higher.
And so it's, it is, you're
getting less for more.
And then there are, you know,
versions of this with
healthcare where maybe,
maybe people are getting a
little bit better healthcare
than they were 30 years
ago but at double the cost.
So it's, again,
you know, a lot of,
it's sort of like
a 80% socialist
healthcare system that we have.
Not a hundred percent, but 80%.
And there's a lot of stuff
that's screwed up with that.
So yeah, I think there are a
lot of things that had not been
working for quite some time.
And maybe the interesting
question is why people
weren't noticing it or
something like that.
- Yeah, so what do
you think that is?
Is that just our modern lives,
we're staring at
our phones all day,
we're watching TV shows
and we're just not paying
attention to what's going on.
- There were still some
parts of our society
where things were progressing.
There was certainly
some, you know,
maybe narrow cone of progress
around computers, software,
internet, mobile internet.
And then those parts where
there was still progress
and where things were
still getting better
also were somehow
distracting us from the lack
of progress everywhere else.
The ways in which we're
not a progressive society,
we use the word progressive.
It gets used all the time,
but it doesn't stand
for actual progress.
And you know, I always say,
you know, the iPhones that,
you know, distract us
from our environment
also distract us from the
way it's strangely old.
So you're looking at an iPhone
while you're riding a hundred
year old subway that's
completely busted in New York.
- Right.
- And so there's
something about, we have
some elements of progress,
but they've been distracting
us from, you know,
the lack of progress or
even the outright decline.
And then it, yeah, there
was some kind of crazy
crystallizing event like
COVID where, you know,
you have no science,
no rationality.
You know, you can't, it
takes a long time to even
get the vaccine approved.
You know, the FDA's
just a blocker.
All these things, you
know, don't work that well.
They still work relatively
better in the U.S.
than many other countries,
but all sorts of things are,
are really off.
- So as the guy that was
the first outside investor
in Facebook and
sort of, you know,
at the beginning of the tech
boom 20 something years ago,
were you thinking about
some of that then?
Or was anyone talking
about the fact
that we might all get distracted
by so much information
and so much nonsense in
scrolling and all of this stuff
that everything else will
just kind of slide away
and we won't even know?
Like was there any
inkling of some of that?
- Well, I didn't, you know,
I think it's always a little
bit unfair to put too much
of the blame on Silicon
Valley for this,
where, you know, there
was some innovation
in Silicon Valley.
There was a sense in
which it probably was not,
not quite enough.
You know, there was a, this
manifesto that my venture
capital fund put
out back in 2011
where the tagline was, you know,
they promised us flying cars
and all we got was
140 characters.
And that wasn't, it wasn't meant
as an anti Twitter argument
per se, you know, like
Twitter, you know,
it's a good business.
It's good for the several
thousand people that work there.
Maybe there were
slightly too many, but-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or at least
for the several
thousand that are left,
it's a good business.
- Yeah.
- It's, and you know, it
somehow was transformative
in some way, but it's
wasn't enough to, you know,
take our whole civilization
to the next level.
And this was, so I
think Silicon Valley
was doing some things,
but it was not enough.
And then, you know, there
were arguments that, you know,
it didn't have to all
be in Silicon Valley.
You know, they weren't
building flying cars
in Silicon Valley.
They weren't building
flying cars anywhere else.
- Right.
So, since you mentioned Twitter,
let's just do an Elon
thing for a second.
As you watch the
guy buy this thing,
obviously you guys did PayPal
together and everything else.
Do you think he realized
what a freaking headache
this thing was gonna become
and how crazy the product
under the hood actually was?
- There was probably,
there was probably,
man, I haven't talked to
him about the Twitter,
the Twitter acquisition.
I think that-
- Or just broadly speaking,
figure, finding that
so many of these things
are sort of broken
under the hood in a way.
- I think, I think
he had some idea,
but probably not
the full extent.
- Yeah.
- Right.
There was probably, you know,
probably the fact that they
were willing to sell Twitter
to him should have told him.
They were just, I mean, it was
just, it was just, you know,
Jack Dorsey, all
these other people.
It was, you know, they
were just these figureheads
and it was, I mean, the inmates
were running the asylum.
- Yeah.
- And it was,
it was probably on
some level, you know,
you know, there was some part
of it that was
somewhat ideological,
there was a way that Elon
felt like the wrong person
ideologically to
take over Twitter.
But I mean, after a decade
of the stock going nowhere,
they were just
completely exhausted.
- Yeah.
You can only lose
money for so long.
I don't know that much
about business, but.
- They didn't lose
money, but they didn't,
if you look at the
Twitter price the day,
at the end of the first day
of trading, so, you know,
price the IPO, it
closes on day one,
and I forget what
the exact number was.
- Oh, I think it was, it
was roughly the same, right?
- It was roughly the same
as at the point where Elon
offered to acquire it.
So it had gone
nowhere in a decade.
- Yeah.
- In a context
where a lot of tech
stocks had gone up.
- Right.
- So I think they were,
they were just
completely exhausted
and it was sort of
a plea for help.
And then Elon probably on
some level realized it,
and on some level didn't
realize quite how, you know,
please take this
company from us.
And, and you know,
you can hear that as
Elon, you're wonderful,
you can do a great job.
Or we're just really,
really exhausted.
- Right.
- It probably
was some combination of both.
- Right, so, all right.
So let's shift a little bit.
I want to talk to you,
one of the things that we've
covered an awful lot on my show
in the last two months is a
lot of the globalist stuff
and the WEF and the
meetings in Davos
and all of these things.
And I always try to say
when I'm doing these things
on the show, it's like I
don't have a full sense
of how much influence
these organizations
actually have versus just they
give these crazy speeches.
We all kind of
freak out about it.
But what are actually
the policies?
And then on the other hand,
you see someone maybe
like a Justin Trudeau
who seems like he
really is incorporating
a lot of the
policies of the WEF.
So as someone that, you've
been to some of these things
over the years, right?
Like what do you make of
what actually goes on there?
I assume you're usually
kind of on the outside,
even if you're there.
- Yeah.
- Just because of your
political leaning.
- I went to the WEF three
times, 2008, 2009, 2013.
So I haven't been
in about a decade.
It is, I mean, there's things
about it that are maybe,
maybe talking something
about globalism generally.
It is somehow this
official ideology.
It is, it's in some
ways very exhausted.
So it's, I think the
tide is going out.
The high watermark
year was probably 2007.
- Hmm.
- And it's been going
out in some way for 16 years,
but it's been going
out very, very slowly.
And there are sort of
ways that it is, you know,
in theory, you know, a
borderless, more integrated,
more peaceful world, is a good
world for the 21st century.
- Theory, sure.
- That's good globalization.
- Right.
- And then there
are all kinds of versions
of it that are kind of bad,
where it just ends up being,
you know, a racket for,
you know, dictators
stealing money
and stashing it in
Swiss bank accounts,
which probably with Davos
you can think of as a sort
of reputation
laundering operation
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Or there are all
sorts of versions
of it that are,
you know, deeply,
deeply unhealthy.
And I think it has been
on this kind of autopilot
where it just keeps going even
though it's very exhausted.
I think it's been
exhausted for 15 years.
- Is that why in some
ways the rhetoric
seems to ramp up
where, you know,
they really are making it
sound like we control you
and we are the gods.
And it's sort of like hysterical
because perhaps there actually
isn't, I mean, that would be,
I would love that as
the takeaway here.
- Yeah, there probably are
all these different vectors
of globalization.
There's, you know, trade
is the movement of goods,
movement of people is sort
of immigration policy,
movement of money is
banking and finance and,
and then movement of
ideas is the internet.
And so there's sort of a,
those are, you can sort of
analyze it in terms of these,
these different sectors.
And there were, in theory,
all these ways these
things should work.
In theory, you
know, free trade is,
is a positive sum exercise
where both sides benefit.
You know, I think it was, you
know, Adam Smith who said,
you know, why would
anybody ever throw rocks
in their own harbor?
And then, you know, being
able to move, you know,
between countries and
places is also something
that you might expect to see
in a dynamic healthy world.
So there are sort
of all kinds of ways
these things are in
theory pretty good.
And then in practice
they went very haywire.
The movement of money piece
was in some ways the global
financial crisis where
people were sending the money
to all these different
places all over the world
where they had no
local knowledge
and it was badly invested
and then the banks blew up.
And that, so that
you can think of 2008
as the financial part of
globalization kind of blew up.
And then you know, one
version would be, well,
it's gonna just stop and we're
gonna stop sending the money.
And it sort of got
replaced by governments.
So if you think about Europe,
sort of a mini
globalization in the form
of the European Union, the EU.
And basically in 2007,
German savers were voluntarily
buying Italian bonds
and sort of this
international financial flows.
After 2008, nobody wanted
to do that anymore,
but the Northern European
government stepped in,
and started doing it and somehow
kept that game going for,
for another decade or so.
But yeah, my intuition is
that it's very exhausting.
There's obviously a
China version of this.
- Yeah.
- Where, you know, in 2007,
people still talked about
globalization as, you know,
all the developing countries,
and they were gonna converge
with a developed world.
And it was sort of,
it was a sort of convergence
theory of history.
And in some ways that
story got dominated
much more by China.
And there are, you
know, there are sort of,
there are ways in which
China has been growing,
but it's actually
not been globalizing,
if globalizing means
becoming, you know,
sort of a, a western
liberal democracy.
And so China's
actually, you know,
this place that
hasn't been following
that script terribly well.
And if the biggest
country in the world
doesn't fit the picture
of globalization
at some point should tell you,
you know, the theory's wrong.
- Right.
- End of history theory
was a version of globalization.
And I always say that,
you know, in 2000,
you know, the end of history
itself was obviously over,
ended in 2017 when Xi becomes
dictator for life, you know?
- Right.
So I think-
- And the biggest country
isn't gonna-
- I think Blake,
Blake Masters, who you
co-wrote "Zero to One" with,
I think his line on China was
we thought that we would make
China more like us basically
by having a conversation
with China about what's
going on with the world.
And instead we became
more like China.
So I take it you probably agree
with that premise, generally?
- It's a very disturb,
it's a, you know,
it has a great deal of very
disturbing truth to it.
And where yeah, there's
sort of all this, you know,
social credit scoring,
centralized control.
Obviously we're still very
far ways off from China.
You know, I wouldn't
wanna move there.
China is a lot worse than
China was 10 years ago.
- Mm-hmm.
- I mean, you know,
I think, you know,
I think it was,
you know, it was a one party
communist state in 2012,
but I don't think it
felt as heavy handed
and as totalitarian
as it does now.
I mean, there's, I don't know
what the right metaphor is.
It's like the Cylons in
"Battlestar Galactica,"
where they've just
been, the tech is just,
it's like all the
surveillance tech.
Everyone's being monitored
at all times and all places
now in a way that they
were not a decade ago.
- So is the white pill
a version of that,
that it just can't
sustain itself long enough
if you surveil
people constantly,
if you control
everything constantly,
eventually you cannot maintain
that level of control.
Something to that effect.
- There are, you
know, there are,
there are stories
we like to tell
where it's just
going to collapse.
There are, you know, there
are also very pessim-
I think those are
too optimistic.
And I think there are ones
that are, you know, overly,
overly pessimistic where
China's just gonna take over
the whole world.
- Yeah.
- And somehow it's more
efficient or things like that.
And I think both the
extreme optimistic
and extremely pessimistic
stories are probably wrong,
it's somewhere in between.
And, you know, we have
to, we should not assume
it's gonna collapse on its own.
We need to think very
hard about, you know,
you know, how we rise
up to the challenge
that China represents,
and it has, you know,
has all these
dimensions, military,
technological, economic.
It's sort of much
more multifaceted
than the challenge the
Soviet Union was, which was,
you know, much more military
and you know, ideological.
- When you say we, is it like,
is it our political
establishment,
that we are the ones that
are gonna have to deal
with this probably?
Like what actually is we now?
- We is always,
that's a good catch.
We is always a very
ambiguous word.
- Yeah.
- It means we conservatives,
we libertarians, it
means we Republicans-
- Right.
- We Americans
and we the western world
or we all the countries
that are not China.
- Yeah.
Or maybe we.
The two of us!
- Or maybe the two of us.
- Right, like, so, but
what do you mean by that?
Like in a sense of
like if we were-
- All the above.
- Yeah.
- It's all the above.
- You know, there's, there
probably is, you know,
there's always a debate
between, let's say, you know,
the President Trump's policy
was somewhat of a unilateral
anti tough on China policy.
And there's obviously a sense
where a multilateral approach
to China is more
powerful and better.
It's also hard to pull off.
And so multilateralism
in theory is good,
in practice, you have to
always worry that that's,
that's almost like a Chinese
communist decoy tactic
where they're
intentionally encouraging
us to be multilateral
because they know
that will go super slow.
- Right.
Basically like having
the UN do anything-
- Or the WTO, or all these,
all these multinational
agencies that have been,
you know, semi hijacked.
- Yeah.
- So, so yeah.
But I think, yeah,
I think there are,
there are ways in which, yeah,
one should start with
rethinking it on a US level
and then it's definitely
something we need to bring
our allies into.
- Do you think we have enough
sort of, not mental acumen,
but do we have enough
like juice left in America
to tackle things properly?
I think that's what a lot of
people are feeling right now,
that the incompetency
is so across the board,
and Biden is so either
mentally compromised
or has the wrong ideas, or
is staffed the wrong way,
or whatever you wanna call that,
that we just don't
have enough left
to do the right
thing in the world.
- You know, we.
- At least as it stands now.
- There are always
worries that we have,
that we're exhausted.
But I kind of wonder whether
this is just sort of the baby
boomer narrative where,
you know, the boomers were-
- I hope so.
- They were this very
big generation, and then the
country was always defined
by the age the boomers were.
So the 1950s was this
innocent childhood time
because the boomers
were 10 years old,
and the late sixties was
this great youth movement
because the boomers
were all in college,
and the 1980s, the
boomers were yuppies,
and now the boomers
are all retired
and angry old people and then-
- Or hanging on, or hanging on.
- And then that somehow,
that somehow is the
template for the whole US.
So I, you know, I think,
so I think the
complicated answer is,
there's some truth to it because
the boomers have dominated
our society and
they're sort of in a,
in a strange place right
now as a generation.
But they're not
the whole society.
We're not all boomers.
- Do you think that's
a little bit of,
because people are living longer
and medicine has been good and
technology has enabled people
to be sort of functional longer,
that now we're ruled by
octogenarians who, you know,
basically should, you know,
when you see Nancy Pelosi
up there, it's like,
go with your grandchildren,
go play with your grandchildren.
You don't have to be out there
still, or Biden, you know,
it's like they can't
let go because science
in some ways has
kept them going.
- It hasn't changed it,
it's been frustratingly slow.
I mean, we've had some, some
extension of life expectancy
actually reversed the
last few years with COVID
and the opioid
epidemic, et cetera.
But, but no, I think the main,
the main dynamic
was you haven't,
you never had a generation
like the boomers, you know.
I'm, you know, I'm Gen X.
- Yeah.
- You know, there
are millennials
and there's some generational
sensibility you can tell,
or silent generation, there's
some generational story
you can tell around other
people, but the, you know,
the generation with a really
strong identity is the boomers.
And I think it's, there
were just so many of them.
It was like in 1946,
there were 20% more kids
born than 1945 or something.
It was like a step function up,
and then you get the
birth control pill
in the early sixties
and you have fewer babies.
And so it was just, it
was just a lot of people.
- Where does that put us,
the Gen Xers that seemingly
should be doing the thing
right now and I suppose
in some cases we are, but,
but really are the missing
generation in an odd way.
We focus on boomers
and then, you know,
millennials or Zoomers
or whatever it is.
Like we've sort of missed
the people that are between
say 40 and, you
know, late fifties.
- Yeah, I've all these resentful
Gen X things I can say.
But no, I think there's,
there's probably some narrative
where it's a smaller group
and so there's a risk
that you end up being
sort of left out.
I mean, I think
there's some things
where we did perfectly fine.
- Yeah.
- I mean, we had our,
we had our share of, you
know, Olympic gold medalists
because you get those
at a certain age.
And we were at the right
age at a certain point.
You know, it's,
we had 28 years of
boomer presidents,
and I sometimes wonder whether
we're ever gonna have
a Gen X president,
which is just, it's not enough.
And maybe you just skip
to the millennials.
So, you know, the Silicon
Valley story in the 1990s
was the internet companies
were started by Gen X people
and then somehow bought
out, taken over by boomers.
And that's sort of what happened
to almost all the
companies in the nineties.
And then the boomers probably
had a healthier relationship
with the millennials
where it was,
those were, the millennials
were their kids.
And so they were, they
were a little bit nicer
to the millennials
than they were to us.
We were sort of more
their competitors.
- Wow.
- So.
- We were their replacements.
- When PayPal got
acquired by eBay in 2002,
and it was sort of
this boomer company,
and we were this Gen X company,
one of my friends, David
Sack said, you know,
if it would be a movie
it would be called,
"Meet the Parents,"
sort of this stodgy
older people company
was gonna clearly not be fun.
- Yeah.
- When they took over.
But actually you need a,
you need sort of a word for,
for people who are half
a generation older,
not related to you and are
gonna be a lot less nice to you
than your parents, and so.
- Right, we need, we do
need a word for that.
- So I think that it
would be more like,
I dunno, Meg Whitman would
be like, more meet the,
the evil young stepmother.
- Right, right.
So actually since
you mentioned Sacks,
do you find it interesting if
you were to look back 20 years
ago and boy, you know,
Elon's doing everything
he's doing now.
You've done incredible things.
You know, Sacks is becoming
an outspoken political voice.
You know, really anti-war.
He's one of the people
leading that thing,
that this crew of you know,
the PayPal mafia, so to speak.
You guys are all still
in the mix in a odd way.
Is there something special
about what was going
on there 20 years ago?
- It was.
- Or it's more
than 20 years at this point.
- You know, it's always hard to,
it's hard to tell the story.
It was, it was,
I don't think we really
appreciated it at the time,
but yeah, it was a
phenomenal group of people.
There's always, there's
always a sense where PayPal
didn't really succeed in
that big a way, you know,
it was a successful
exit in 2002,
it was you know, one and a half
billion acquisition by eBay.
But it didn't, you know,
we couldn't figure out how to
run the business on our own.
It made sense to
combine it with eBay
for all sorts of reasons.
It was, you know, you know,
in some ways a depressing,
but a very rational thing-
- Hmm.
- To do, and then-
- Did you feel that at the time?
That maybe you wanted to
hold on a little bit longer
or something like that?
- It, we didn't, it
was hard to see a path
to an independent
business where, you know,
eBay had the store and we were
running the cash registers
and the people running the
store were trying to figure
out how to get their own cash
register machines to work
and figured it out one time
we'd be sort of out of business
and then the ways you
could gradually diversify
away from eBay and, but it
took like a decade in practice.
So I think, you know,
I think the combination
made a lot of sense,
but then it somehow short
circuited the business,
whereas, you know, so many
of the other tech companies
just scaled and
scaled and scaled,
which like the Google history
or something like that.
And that would've
been, you know,
a far more successful version,
but probably would've
done less, you know,
if you, if you were,
if you had, you know,
if you'd got gotten on
board the Google rocket
at the right time, you should
have just never gotten off.
- Right.
When you see the
frustrations that people
have with these things,
you know, the sort of lack
of trust in these things,
you know, is the government
working to silence
you on Twitter?
Or how is Google manipulating
the search results
or all of these things?
Do you also see those
as inevitable problems
that were gonna happen
with these things?
The reason I ask is I heard
you give a talk at NatCon,
you gave the keynote
speech last year.
And one of the things you said
was that nobody represents
the individual at
these big conferences.
And I sort of think
that's the same problem
that we have with tech.
Nobody represents the
individual anymore.
We just have these
giant corporations that,
or these giant tech companies
that make decisions.
You cannot get
somebody on the phone.
You can't actually
communicate as yourself.
You, there is, you know, there's
a business version of it,
something like that.
- Yeah, there probably
are all kinds of ways
they have biases
in that direction.
You know, there's
always Nom Chomsky,
the communist MIT professor.
I always like to quote him
on this where he says that,
you know, the Republicans
are the parties,
the party of business, but
the Democrats discriminate.
The Democrats are the
party of big business.
- Yeah.
- And there's sort
of like a center left.
- Look at you, quoting a
communist, there you go.
- Well, you know-
- Every now and again.
- Entirely wrong about
things or, you know.
But, there's sort of a
central left sensibility
where, you know, basically big
businesses can be regulated.
They'll follow all the rules.
Small businesses, you know,
they often make a
little bit more money
by being a gray area,
not following the
rules to the letter.
And so there is probably just
this structural anti small
business bias that's
you know, political,
regulatory, cultural,
partisan, that's very deep.
- Yeah, were you
shocked how obvious
that became during COVID?
I mean, where, you know,
Target could stay open for,
you know, the big box store,
but the mom and pop that was
selling the exact same thing
next door got closed.
That shows the bias
right there, right?
The system just
kind of eliminated a
certain set of people.
- Yes, I think, I
mean, I think it was,
yeah, it was a, I mean a
dramatic shift in terms
of the power of big relative
to small businesses.
And it probably, I dunno,
I think in some ways COVID
surfaced all these realities
that had been there
for a long time.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, this was,
this was the institutional
center left establishment
in this country.
You know, it's good
with big business,
it's anti, it's very
anti small business.
- How did you fight some of
that with your businesses
during COVID and
figuring out, you know,
were people gonna
work from home or,
or just all of the nonsense
that everybody dealt with?
Did you try to give as much
power to your employees
and say, do what
you gotta do or?
- Well, you know, most of the-
- 'Cause even now
a lot of the people
still don't want to come back.
That's one of the problems
that Elon's having.
- Most of the tech
companies were pretty
well positioned
to adapt to COVID,
where, you know, if you're,
there were sort of ways you
could do the remote work.
You could work remotely,
do things like that.
And it seemingly didn't
hurt the business too much.
And then of course there was,
there was a way
where COVID shifted
a lot to the internet.
So a lot of the tech companies
in which I'm involved,
you know, got a, got a big
temporary boost from COVID
even though, you know,
maybe they, maybe they actually
got, you know, more bloated,
less well managed in the
last two, three years.
And that's what I worry about.
- Yeah.
- So it was,
it was actually sort
of a windfall for them.
And then the question
is just did they,
did they really take
advantage of it,
or did they get even more
dysfunctional in various ways?
- Do you think more
people in the tech world,
or maybe even in
the political world
actually think like
you to some degree,
but because of the way
we, the hive mind is,
or the globalist movement
or whatever it is,
they just sort of
always go to that.
But I think, you know,
if you privately sat
down with these people
about what their real
beliefs in the individual
are in capitalism
in these things.
- Directionally yes.
But I think it, I always
wonder if it actually works
if you can't say it.
So, so yes, surely it's almost
the definition of political
correctness that
it distorts things.
- Yeah.
- And that there are
all sorts of people who are,
people are less politically
correct than they appear to be,
because political correctness
is about appearances.
And then the reality's
always that people
are gonna think it's
a little bit crazy.
You know, there probably
are a lot of parents
who think the schools
went very crazy.
But, but then if you
feel like you can't talk
about it or articulate it,
it's not going to be that
well formed a view at all.
And so that's, and so I think
the political correctness is,
is real to the extent
it just stops people
from saying things.
You don't actually get
to a very considered
non-politically correct opinion.
- Right, it's interesting,
'cause that also then
gets to the stagnation
part that you're talking about.
If people can't talk about
what the actual issues are,
then you really
don't have to wonder
why we're so stagnated and
why we got 140 characters
instead of flying cars.
- Sure.
There's probably some way
all these things, yeah,
all these things are linked.
But, but yeah,
I think if we live in a society
where there are an
awful lot of topics
that are somewhat off
limits, you know, where,
you know, and if we
think about science,
let's think about sort of
freedom of speech or debate
in the area of science.
And I always think you
can describe science
as involving a two
front war in theory.
Should be a two
front war against
excessive dogmatism and
excessive skepticism.
So excessive dogmatism in the
17th, 18th century context,
it's like the Catholic church
or it's this sort of decayed
Aristotelianism and you
know, a scientist, you know,
needs to think for
themselves and challenge
the sort of ossified dogmas
or ossified metaphysics.
And you just do an experiment,
you think for yourself.
But then you also
can't be a scientist
if you're too skeptical.
So if I don't think you exist,
I think you're just
a simulation or-
- Yeah.
- Everything's fake.
Nothing's real.
I'm just in a brain being,
I'm just a brain in a
vat being manipulated
by mad scientists.
- That's why I got bored
of interviewing atheists.
- That's not a good
world for science either.
- Yeah.
- So you can't
be too dogmatic, you
can't be too skeptical.
- Yeah.
- And sort of probably
healthy version of
science cuts against
both excess dogmatism
and excess skepticism.
But my scoring is, it's all
anti skepticism at this point.
The scientific establishment,
it's all circling the wagons.
- Yeah.
- And we have
a climate change skeptic,
we have a, you know,
you can't be skeptic
of, you know,
you can't be a vaccine skeptic,
you can't be a
skeptic of anything.
And so it's all
against skepticism,
which is of course the
exact opposite of, you know,
let's say a children's
science book
would be that a scientist
thinks for themselves
and is against dogmatism,
not against skepticism.
- So what do we do?
What do we do to
break outta that?
- It's 80% anti dogmatism,
20% anti skepticism.
That's healthy science.
We're in a world where
it's a hundred percent
anti skepticism.
And that's a tell that
it's hyper dogmatic
and that the scientists, no,
the scientists can't talk
freely about the science.
And if you have, you
know, if you have,
if you have dissenting views,
you better keep them to yourself
or your government
funding will get cut off
and they're, you know, they're
all in the sort of government
welfare or something like that.
- I mean, look at the
last three years of COVID
and I think you pretty much
get your answer, right?
- A shockingly narrow range of
discourse allowed in science.
- Was there a
moment during COVID-
- Science in scare quotes.
- Yeah, right.
So was there a
moment during COVID
where you realized how
dysregulating that effect was?
That you couldn't get a counter?
I mean, I saw you a
couple times during COVID
for dinners and things,
and it was like we
weren't wearing masks
and we were sitting there,
I don't even know
if you were allowed
to have people at your house.
Like, but humans continued
and yet the machine
just kept telling you, no,
stay in your house and wear
the masks and get the vax,
and do-do-do.
- I had a lot of skepticism
about all these things
before I would say.
- Yeah.
- Or the skepticism
of the excessive
dogmatism of science.
- Yeah.
- And I think,
I think that had, but
yes, it was still,
it was still strike, it was
like you had these, I dunno,
you had these public
health officials,
all these people were,
it was just, again,
the opportunity to really
to push it in a conformist
standardized way.
It was, what was
extraordinary about it,
wasn't just the dogmatism
and the uniformity,
but it was, it was the
Orwellian character
where we pivoted radically
from black to white,
A to not A and so,
you know, it was,
it was, I'm not gonna
get, the history was so,
it was so many twists and turns,
it's hard to even
keep it straight.
But I believe October, 2020,
it was still Kamala
Harris saying
that she would never
take a vaccine.
- Yeah.
- A Trump vaccine.
- A Trump vaccine, yeah.
- And then, you know,
and then when I-
- That you literally
shouldn't trust the agencies
because he has
something to do with it.
That's what she said.
- And then, you know,
and then a year later
it's like you're a really crazy
person if you don't get one.
So we had these sort
of Orwellian twists
in the narrative.
- Yeah.
- You know, there was,
there was the thing where
originally the masks
didn't work because they
were trying to lie to save
the mask for the hospital
workers or something.
- Right.
- And then you
pivoted on that.
There was, you know, anyway,
there was all these, these
crazy twists and turns.
There was, you know,
there was the initial,
the very initial one where,
you know, it was just,
we shouldn't shut the border
because that's anti-globalist.
And then when Trump, you know,
and then when
President Trump didn't,
wasn't restrictive enough,
then somehow it all shifted
into the sort of
pure nanny state.
- Yeah, so it seems like
it all flipped almost,
I think this is
what you're saying,
it happened so quickly that we
almost couldn't react, like,
so the same people who were
saying, my body, my choice,
were the same ones yelling at
you that you must be injected
with the thing I
wanna inject you with.
And I think that was
so dysregulating.
- Sort of like, it was like,
you know, the sky is blue,
but no, they were
saying the sky is green
and then the sky is orange
and then the sky is yellow.
So it was just this dizzying
shift in the dogmas.
It wasn't like the Catholic
church in the Middle Ages
where at least the
dogmas stayed the same
for a few hundred years.
- Yeah.
- They don't,
they didn't change them
like every six months.
- So what does that tell you,
I guess this is a little bit
of what you're doing
at Stanford now.
What does that tell you
about people's belief systems
and how they operate?
- Well, it's, it is-
- 'Cause they seem to believe
anything on any given day.
You could almost, depending
on who was president
and what their, you
know, party was,
you could get virtually
anyone to say almost anything.
- Yeah, I would say, I would,
I mean it's hard to do
sweeping generalizations
about our society, but it's
striking how many things
are not very well
thought through at all.
And there are, yeah,
I think there are,
there's some set of things
where things are doctrinaire
and dogmatic and then
they're all kinds of issues
that barely even
register as problems
and we don't even talk about.
So I, yeah, I think
there's this, yeah,
this official ideology,
but it's almost like a
magic show hypnotic trick
where you know, it
redirects our attention
from other things.
So people have, yeah,
they have very well defined
opinions on the vaccine
and those are sort
of officially set.
But then if we talk about a
topic like tech stagnation
or how fast are we developing
vaccines generally,
how fast are we curing other
diseases besides COVID?
That's something people
don't even think about.
- Right.
What are you thinking about
that maybe the average person
isn't thinking about?
Like if we're to get to the
other side of the stagnation
and let's say we start breaking
through some of this stuff,
which we will eventually,
some society has to,
I think to some degree, what
should we be thinking about?
- Well, there are, I mean,
there are, there are a lot of,
there are a lot of
different topics one could,
I mean, I dunno, there's
some that I've, you know,
I feel I've thought about,
there's probably a small number
that I always keep
coming back to, that.
But-
- I got one I want you
to come back to, I'll
tell you in a second,
but I wanna hear what you-
- Probably the, you know,
the big one is always just,
you know, I don't think
our society's progressing
that quickly in that
many dimensions.
Why has it slowed?
What's gone wrong?
Why has that happened?
And that's probably, that's
probably the big topic
question theme that
I've come back to over
the last two decades,
over and over again.
And then there are, yeah,
there's all sorts of different
answers one can get to.
There probably are good
reasons for us to be so slow,
but I think it pushes you to
ask a lot of deep questions
about our society,
that it would be good
for us to think about more.
- So the one that I don't
know if you're thinking
about at all anymore,
I suspect you are at
least at some level,
is you were really
interested in seasteading
a couple probably what,
15 or so years ago,
this idea that there could sort
of be these libertarian utopias-
- Yes.
- Sort of international
waters where people could
do experimental medication
and operations and
things of this nature.
To me, it feels like so
many people have such a lack
of faith in the system,
that there's an
opportunity there again.
Does, is that registering
with you at all?
Is it, do you feel like
the operation is gone?
Has someone else picked up
maybe where you left off?
- They are still trying to,
trying to do it in various ways.
It's not that easy to do.
You know, there probably are,
on some level there are
technological issues
where it's not that
cheap to build.
- Right, okay.
- And then,
and then there are all these
reasons where, you know,
you have to sort
of, if you do that,
you have to, if you have
something that's floating,
what if, you know, if
you have a freak storm
once every 20 years,
how do you model that?
You know, if you have a ship,
you can move it out
of the way, but-
- Yeah.
- Seastead not so much.
So it turns out to be, you know,
it turns out to be quite hard.
But what was, you know, it
was sort of the small side
project I started was
Milton Friedman's grandson,
Patrick Friedman, who
pitched us on it in,
I think it was 2007, 2008.
And what was surprising to me
was how much it caught fire
as, you know, not
as a technology,
but just as a
thought experiment.
Because even if these seasteads
are very hard to build,
it was obvious that, that if
we could redesign our society,
if we could somehow start over,
we would do it so differently.
And there are all these,
there are all these legacy
structures that are
very hard to undo.
May, I mean, don't necessarily
want a total revolution,
but there are all these
ways that we're in a place
that no one would,
if you looked at it
from first principles,
no one would build a
society like we have today.
- So is there a way to do that,
maybe just not doing it
by building a structure
in the ocean, like finding
some land in the middle
of the country and just trying
it at sort of a micro level?
- Yeah, well there's obviously,
there's obviously no,
there's obviously this sort
of movement between different
parts of the country
that has been accelerated
or restarted post COVID
that I think is very
important, very healthy.
Yeah, and then there are,
there's still all
sorts of things
you can do on a
city county level.
It's, you know, there were also
reasons it was non-trivial.
You know, there are
a lot of, a lot of,
a lot of cities are
unusually dysfunctional,
but they also are very
powerful economic networks.
And so there's sort
of a reason, you know,
in a place like San
Francisco, you know,
I lived there for a long time.
It was very dysfunctional
on a governance side,
but it was, you know, it
was also in the middle
of this gold rush tech boom.
And then it actually,
it wasn't that it
was, that you had,
you had this bad governance
sort of in contradiction
of the tech boom.
It was almost like
the bad governance
came with a tech boom.
It was just like, people
were fine paying this tax
because they were doing so well.
And so there sort of are,
there are these natural
network effects,
these natural economies of
scale that come with cities.
But that also paradoxically,
if you're not very careful,
lead to extremely
bad governance.
And so, you know,
there are, you know,
there are a lot of relatively
unregulated states,
but there aren't any people,
not enough people there.
So it's sort of, you know,
there's a way that Alaska,
Wyoming, South
Dakota, New Hampshire,
they're all fairly unregulated.
But to the extent that
what we do as human beings
has a social component,
the sort of networked component,
they could, you could
never get the critical mass
of people to move
there to make it work.
- Do you sense that the states
will just continue to
go their separate ways,
that we'll just sort of see
that and that will be a natural,
that it'll actually kind of
be okay as long as they agree
not to go to war or
something like that?
- I think there's, I
think there's some of it.
It's, I wish there were more.
- Yeah.
- But, I think,
I think, I know, I think
that that's probably
what's still, you know,
very healthy about the U.S.
is that it's still somewhat
of a Federalist system.
There still is, you know,
some degree to which
the states are genuinely
different places, and you
have these 50 different
experiments and you, it's not
all about politics and voting.
It's also about, you
know, economics and exit.
- What do you make about
what's going on culturally
in the country in terms of,
you know, the Super Bowl?
It was a couple weeks
ago, I watched, like,
I'm watching the commercials.
They didn't feel, I
didn't feel any attachment
to any of the
cultural references.
The halftime show,
like as Breitbart said,
you know, politics is
downstream from culture.
It seems like we
don't have a culture
that's unifying
us in any way now.
- Yeah, I, it's always so hard.
It's always so hard
to know exactly,
exactly what's going on.
It's probably, you know,
if there was something
that would be unifying,
I don't know that we
would like it that much.
Like it would be, it would be
like a crazy woke religion.
- Right.
- And, you know, it's,
I'm always hopeful that
the insanity, you know,
has crested and is receding.
And so, so yes.
If we had something
that would be unifying,
it would be, it would be the
woke religion on steroids,
shove down everyone's throats.
And, it's probably, you
know, it's probably,
the fact that it has this sort
of not very strong slightly
nihilistic feel may actually be,
be relatively healthy.
- Right, that's the white pill.
- It may be relatively healthy.
- So in terms of better things
for people to believe in,
so you are, can I say
teaching this course?
Are you actually teaching
this course at Stanford?
What do you, what do you co-
- I've co-taught, yeah-
- Yeah.
- Courses at Stanford
occasionally over the years.
It's always, yeah,
a lot of work,
but sort of fun process
to think about things and-
- Yeah, so what
are you doing now?
'Cause obviously you don't
need the gig, obviously.
You're doing this
because you enjoy it.
- We're just doing
forbidden topics
and this quarter we're
doing political theology,
which means basically what
does politics tell us about God
and what does God tell
us about politics?
And they're both these
deeply transgressive,
forbidden questions.
I started, I'm starting to
wonder if these questions
of religion are, you
know, somehow they are,
I'm not saying they're
necessarily the most important,
but they're, they are
the most transgressive.
They're the ones that
somehow we can't ask at all.
And there's something, there's
something very generative
in looking at that
prism through, you know,
through a lot of
different lenses.
You know, what is the
religion in our society?
What is it that people,
what is that people value,
and then, yeah,
how does that work?
- Yeah, so what would you
say is the sort of broad
answer to that?
What is the religion
of the people here
from an American
perspective right now,
in a system that seems
to be very obviously
shaking to most people?
- Again, it's always
hard to do these sweeping
generalizations, but it is,
you know, it's in some sense,
you know, it's in some
sense, I think of it,
I think of the woke
liberal religion
as a kind of antithesis,
but also a kind of
intensification of
the Judeo-Christian
tradition where, you know,
both Judaism and Christianity
look at it from the
side of the victim.
You know, the Jewish
people are the victims
in the Old Testament, you
know, Pharaoh is the oppressor.
You know, there's a way in
which Christ is the victim
in the New Testament.
And there's something
that's very true
and very powerful
about this, you know,
reorientation towards,
towards the victim,
towards, you know, justice
against oppression.
- Well that's interesting.
So you think over the course
of thousands of years,
basically, the victim
idea was just baked in.
So wokeness is just an
extension of that in some ways.
- And then in some, in some
weird way it went into,
you know, hyper
overdrive or, you know,
and then there's
always, you know,
the Christian version's
it always ends up
becoming this competitive
thing where people try
to be more Christian
than the Christians.
And so, you know,
you know, you know,
the poor shall inherit the
earth, sermon on the mount,
and then, you know, Tolstoy
remarks the 19th century,
it's no, we need to, you know,
we need to actually
intensify that,
and we need to have a
violent communist revolution
and accelerate that
process in this world.
And, and, and then I think,
I think sort of a lot
of, yeah, a lot of,
a lot of the woke religion
can be thought of this,
as this incredible
intensification of this.
And of course, you know,
there are all these paradoxes
where people use their victim
status as a stick with
which to beat other people
over the head.
And so there's sort of all
these, you know, all these,
all these dynamics about it,
it's obviously not particularly
Christian in that, you know,
you still have this,
this great sense of
historical injustice,
but there's no forgiveness.
- Yeah, right, right.
There's a lot of
revenge there, yeah.
- Yeah, it's sort, it's,
but it's always this,
it's always this revenge
in the name of, you know,
wronging injustice.
- How do you find
teaching a course at,
or co-teaching a
course at Stanford?
I mean, you are one
of the guys that said,
hey, you don't have
to go to college.
As a matter of fact,
my producer here,
I was having dinner
at your house once,
and I was like, I really
wanna hire this guy.
He wants to go back to college.
And you were like, you
gotta tell him don't go back
to college.
- Yes.
- And now it all worked out.
But, so there's a little bit
of a tension there, right?
- Oh, I, sure.
There are all these,
all these things I do that are
somewhat self contradictory,
but it's, you
know, I don't know.
It's, I'm against
social security,
but I'm gonna get a
social security check
if it's still around.
And if, you know, if I
was, you know, if I was,
you know, if I could
take advantage of
diversity in hiring,
I would definitely use
diversity quotas to help myself.
So even so, I think
there's nothing,
there's nothing
hypocritical about-
- Is that just the honest
version of all of it?
I mean, I always felt
that that was Trump's
honest version of all of it.
They'd be angry at
Trump over taxes,
and it was like,
well, don't blame me,
blame you guys who created
all these stupid rules.
- I think it's
always complicated.
You know, there are
all these, yeah,
there are all these different
dimensions going on.
But I think, look, I think the,
I think that there is
a way that, you know,
teaching a course is a terrific
forcing function for me
personally to think
about a lot of topics.
And so, you know, I get
a lot out of doing it.
I don't read enough books.
It's a way to force
me to do that.
On the other hand,
in the same breath,
I can also say that
this doesn't happen
in most other college courses.
That most of it is,
is sort of this
debt driven racket
that's gone very out of control,
where it's 300 billion
in student debt in 2000,
up to 2 trillion in 2020.
And, and yeah, it's in
the context of this,
of this larger system that's,
that's very, very broken.
So, so I think, and
then I think, you know,
there are, there are
sort of, you know,
there's always this duality
between exit and voice.
And so there is, you know,
there is a version where, yeah,
it would be good for fewer
people to go to college
and for people to
vote with their feet.
And then at the same time,
there's always something to be
said for still trying to do,
you know, to fight the fight.
You know, and I, you know,
I went to Stanford, so I,
I have a certain, certain
attachment to that university
and, you know, want to
still try to do something
on the ground to make
it a better place.
Even though maybe it's
like, maybe it's like,
maybe it's like
fighting, you know,
the San Francisco city board
or something like that,
board supervisors.
- Right, although I've
told you many times
it's a lot more fun to be in
Florida fighting for something
than always fighting
against something,
which is what I
was doing in Cali,
which I would imagine
there's probably a time
for both of those, right?
- Yeah, well, it's,
but yeah, it's,
there, but I think
we should always,
there's a trade off
between exit and voice,
but you wanna think of both.
- Yeah.
Do you think about that?
I mean, just in general, like,
you can do whatever you want.
Like you, if you wanted
to disappear altogether
and go to-
- It's not that easy,
not that easy to do.
- Yeah.
But you know, roughly.
- It's Ouray, Colorado.
- Yeah?
- That's-
- That's the spot?
You're not supposed to say.
- That's the town-
- Oh, oh, right.
Of course, of course.
- There's an actual town
in Colorado.
- Yeah.
Yeah, but I mean, do
you ever think like.
- It's about a thousand
people who live there.
I thought of just yeah,
buying a bunch of real estate
there, but not quite sure.
- Let me just ask you
one or two other things,
just circling back to some
of the things we covered.
So we talked a bit about
the globalist stuff and WEF
and all that stuff.
When you see this sort
of like wide variance,
I think between say
someone like you and Elon,
who I think are, you know,
mostly lined up together,
let's say, and then how that
seems so starkly different
than someone like Bill Gates,
and yet you guys all seemingly
came out of something
roughly similar.
Does that seem bizarre to you
that people evolve
so differently?
Is that the right way
to frame the question?
- You know, I, man,
I never wanna even
compare myself to Elon.
That's always a dangerous
thing where you always
end up losing to Elon.
But I think I would say I am.
- Well you guys are seemingly
fighting for the same things.
- I'm always disturbed
by the degree
to which tech has become
the sort of San Francisco,
Silicon Valley, is close
to a one party state.
- Yeah.
- And you know,
there's a way in
which, you know,
Elon is a dissident
from that at this point.
You know, I've been,
I've been a dissident
for a long time.
And, and yeah, and
then what this,
but what this sort of, you know,
strange conformity
means, you know,
it's, it's, I can, you can
come up with sociological
explanations, you know,
I'm tempted to do
something like, you know,
the people were somehow
narrowly trained
in computer science, which
was very, very important
and very useful, but then
they never actually thought
about most of these broader
social, political, cultural
issues much at all.
- Right.
- And I, you know,
I don't know Bill
Gates terribly well,
but I think he's probably a
fairly high IQ smart person,
but I think he
never really thought
about this stuff very much
and then just somehow went
with the wisdom of crowds,
went with a liberal consensus.
- Right, 'cause
it's bizarre, he's-
- That's my
sociological explanation
because I can't,
I can't actually-
- Right.
- I can't come up
with an explanation how a
person would sort of rationally
really get to these answers.
- Well, because I think
then you see people
seeing him on TV all the time
and it's like he's the largest
farm, landowner in the
United States suddenly,
or farm owner in
the United States.
And you know, he has all this
stuff to do with the vaccines
and all these things.
And I think most people
are like, wait a minute,
weren't you a
programmer 30 years ago?
Like, what happened here
that got you to think
you can sort of be, you
know, king of the world,
something like that.
- Well, there are,
there are, there are,
I mean, I don't know,
there are all sorts of
ways you should probably,
you know, be, you should
try to sort of steelman
what Bill Gates is doing.
I mean, there was some place
where he made a lot of money
at Microsoft and
probably was not entirely
satisfied with that.
Certainly not with where
it was reputationally
for him at the end where it
was sort of this, you know,
cutthroat monopolist charges
and then there was, you know,
this attempt over the last
decade and a half to reinvent
himself as this sort of
leading philanthropist.
And, and I, so I, I
think you can, I dunno.
And then there were versions
where this was sincere.
There were versions
where this was just
some sort of
rebranding exercise.
I think it was
probably more sincere
than just a rebranding.
But, you know, obviously had
elements of all these things.
- Sure.
- And then,
and then I think, yeah,
I think there are probably
ways one can also be critical
where my guess is that he
did more good for the world
at Microsoft, even though it
was in many ways, you know,
all these things were
problematic about
it as a business,
but Microsoft did more
good for the world
than the Gates
Foundation has done.
And then that's
a very odd thing.
So that's not what, that's not-
- Right.
- And I don't think that's-
- That's interesting.
- That's not what
Gates expected.
- Yeah.
- And, but it is, there's
something about the consensus
sort of center
left establishment
that is just really
exhausted and, you know,
it would've been good if he'd
thought about these things,
you know, with a
little bit, you know,
a little bit less of
a doctrinaire mindset.
- All right.
So then to ask you
one more question,
not about Bill Gates,
but about yourself
related to all that,
you've been early
on a lot of things.
You were early on getting
outta San Francisco
and seeing what
was going on there.
You were early on Trump,
you've been early on plenty,
you were early on Facebook,
all of these things.
Right now, do you feel,
do you feel hopeful?
Do you feel that we can
fix a lot of the things
that we've talked about here
and get through the stagnation
and get to a place where we
can trust some people again
and that the system will
start working right?
Is that a ridiculous exercise?
I mean, what's your
general state of like,
belief in the thing?
- Well it's, I always, I
always think, you know,
extreme optimism,
extreme pessimism are
both equally wrong.
'Cause they're both
excuses for laziness,
for not doing anything.
So I think the answer
is always in between.
- Yeah.
- You know,
as a venture
capitalist, I still,
most of my focus
is on individual
companies and I think,
you know, there are
a lot of, you know,
there are a lot of companies
that can do quite well,
even if our whole society
isn't progressing as quickly
as I would like.
You know, on, you know,
I think the broader
political social questions,
it's very hard.
It is, it is, it is.
You know, it's just
gonna be, you know,
I think a crazy intense
fight for the next decade.
And, you know, my sense is that,
my sense is that we're on we're
on the side I'd wanna be on,
I'm not sure our
side's gonna win, but,
but it's gonna be much
easier to be on our side
than defending all this stuff.
It's just, it's just
there's so much,
so much surface area
that they have to defend.
- Right, and that does seem
like why it gets increasingly
hysterical because they
can't defend it anymore.
So it's constantly the-
- Yeah, you have to-
- The litany of lunacy is just-
- You have to, you
know, you have to,
if you're gonna have these
massive lockdowns in society,
you also have to lockdown debate
and you have to lockdown
speech and you have to,
and that there's
probably some version
of it where it's very unhealthy.
You know, I always, you know,
if you sort of personalize
it in the person
of the president sort of
somehow was a crystallization
of where a society is at.
You know, there are all
these questions about,
you know, you know, you
know, Biden's, you know,
mental acuity and, you know,
maybe he never had that
many marbles to start with.
But, but you know, the
version of it I often wonder
about is whether, you know,
his inability to address
these questions
or speak with him,
is that actually a
feature more than a bug?
Because if you had,
if you had sort of a very
sharp liberal person, like,
I don't know, like,
Pete Buttigieg,
it would just look ridiculous.
Like, you know, we'd
expect some answers,
we'd expect explanations.
He'd be trying to
give us explanations
and they would look so absurd.
- Right, and now all we ask
is that he doesn't, you know.
- And if Biden is just
relaxing in a basement,
that's very protective, maybe.
- You've given us-
- That's maybe the
best they can do.
- I guess that's the
white pill, right?
It's like our enemies
aren't that great.
- I think, you know, I
think, look, I think there,
but yeah, and it's, yeah.
I think there's a
lot of room for,
for things to get better.
- Well, Peter-
- You have to keep
doing the good work
you're doing, David.
- Well as always, it's a
pleasure to talk to you.
And I do wanna, you know, we
do this usually off camera,
but I do wanna publicly
give you a thanks
for something because
about three years ago,
as we sit here in the
local studio, now,
I got on a Zoom call with
you and my partner in Locals
who's sitting in the
other office right there.
And we had an all cash
offer to buy the company.
And you basically said
to us, and I said,
Peter, it's life
changing money for me.
Do you think I should do this?
And you said,
basically you said,
if you believe in it and
you get distribution,
you have a much bigger
opportunity here.
And we waited it out, we
did not take the offer.
And then obviously everything
happened with Rumble.
So I owe you on that front.
How about that, how about that?
- Very good.
- Good to see you, my friend.
- Awesome.
- If you're looking for
a more unfiltered lens
into the world of tomorrow,
check out our tech playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a wide variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.